there is a risk always that if you
antagonize people along racial lines if
you antagonize people along sexuality
lines you end up with a position where
we actually start to roll back some of
the advances we've had and instead of
going well look maybe the trans ideology
has gone too far we got to protect our
children from being encouraged to
transition in one way or another people
start to actually go well this whole
lgbtq thing and gay people all of that
gets thrown out with the bath water got
to be careful so that I think is
actually one of the concerns for me as
well as we adjust and culture starts to
shift perhaps back somewhat or in a
different healthier Direction we've got
to make sure we don't overswing